what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 30th of august it's
almost over but we're still slinging
dick with three hands the joint is
brought to you by blue chew
blue chew is an online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis at a fraction of the
cost listen
blue chew is fantastic you can take it
at any time
day or night day or night the process is
very simple sign up at bluetooth.com
talk to one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days you know he's saying joey listen i
don't suffer from erectile dysfunction
but
you also want to bat a [__] thousand
right you wanted to walk home
looking like she got hit by a [__]
car
right or wrong you want a sling dick
with three hands blue chew is here to
help and if you don't and if you do have
ed
blue chew is the best it's shipped right
to your door in a discreet package
not even your mailman knows what's in
there so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
blue chew can help and they've got a
special deal for you
try blue chew free with promo code joey
just pay five hours for shipping that's
bluechew.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month for free
free [__] and as always i want to
thank bluechu
for sponsoring the podcast listen to me
you can't live without blue chew if
you're a young man an older gentleman
ed is lurking but your [__] blue chew
is here so you can hit it out of the
park you understand me you want both her
eyes to [__] be spinning in the head
like a [__] when you hit the
the casino whatever the hell you call it
you know what i'm talking about
blueshoot.com promo code joey and i'll
take care of you when it comes to the
bedroom
the joint is also brought to you from by
from the heart of [__] jersey
draftkings no more [__] around the
nfl is back jack
if you like getting paid like a [__]
playmate draftking sportsbook is for you
draftking sportsbook is the official
sports betting partner of the nfl
giving all new players a hell of an
offer you ready for this
for the first week
which is week [__] 10 i think
september 10th is when it starts with
two weeks away for the first week you
can bet just one dollar on any game and
cash 200
in three bets
joey what'd you say here we go you bet
one dollar on any game and you cash 200
bucks and free bets instantly
no matter what you heard me right it's
free money draftkings is giving all new
players
200 and free bets when you place a
dollar
on any week
one game bet a dollar and get 200
put down the [__] hummus and take
advantage of this limited time offer
plus make every game big with same game
paulie's
plus they got a tremendous casino plus
they got the baseball playoffs plus the
nba is coming october 19th
college football listen to me if you're
if you don't have draftkings sportsbook
download the draftkings sportsbook app
right now today right now there's tons
of action this weekend use promo code
joey to receive 200 and free bets when
you place a dollar bet on any week one
game that's promo code joey to get 203
bets instantly for a limited time only
at draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the nfl i got
to talk to you about something you got
to be 21 older
new jersey indiana pennsylvania new
customers only restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gambling problem call 1-800 gambler if
you're in indiana call 1-809 with it
but if you got everything under control
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now and let's win some guitars how
am i going to win ghettos uncle joey
listen to me you bet right you bet smart
you can't fall into a trap on here
because every time you place a bet it's
taking the money is taken out of your
account it's easy it's reliable download
the draftking sportsbook app today and
let's make some [__] cash and now
it's time
for the joint [__]
we wasted enough time telling your
stories
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
welcome to uncle joey's joint it's
monday the 30th of august we're almost
out of this [__]
on to the [__] fall you have to put
your whites away
excuse me there some [__] [__]
dust was floating around the [__] air
and i got it in my goddamn nose here i'm
happy you guys made it through another
week i had a great week last week
i'm sorry uh to my patreon followers
last week i had to do the intros
acapella off the phone
i went to [__] pittsburgh i shot for
two days
then me and the girls went to hershey
park if you've never been [__]
tremendous just
tremendous and the [__] chocolate
making was sold out i was pissed
because that's what i [__] went there
for i must have walked around 14 weight
watcher points it was great
no complaints at all you know i'm not
really a [__] disney guy
every time you go to disney you walk you
walk you walk
and everything you want is on the other
[__] side of the thing you know it's
one [__] 40 140
so the whole time you're there you
you're like am i getting [__] in the
ass i mean what am i doing here at
[__] disney it's a [__] ripoff you
feel like you're getting ripped off last
time i went to disney it was me
my wife my daughter
eddie bravo his wife
his son
we did that package i can't tell you how
much it [__] cost
and you look at it and you go you know
what i don't even want to know because
it's for the kids anyway it's not about
us but disney is just a [__]
nightmare the time i went right and
thank god they didn't let me in like
sometimes people are doing you a [__]
favor and you're too stupid to [__]
know
the last time i went to disney we got a
hotel room on the disneyland [__]
whatever me and eddie had conjoining
rooms we talked [__] all night i [__]
went to sk i went to sleep petrified
from the conspiracy theories
the whole thing walt disney's still
alive you know the [__] deal
so uh
the next morning we wake up we go to
breakfast
and we're about to walk into the park
but to have metal [__] detectors
right so
i walk to the [__] metal detector and
the lady goes there's something in your
pocket yeah my wallet my phone you know
she goes take them out and put them in
the canister so i put everything in a
little container like at the airport and
you run it through and often she goes
hold on
what is this and it was a [__]
chibacho
and she goes what is this and i go it's
an edible i have a
situation i get anxiety and these
edibles have controlled me and she
started going off on me you're not
allowed to bring this into the park
walk this back to your room like okay no
problems
so i go back to the hotel
and i take a bite off the chibachu which
is 90 milligrams and i throw the other
half away i go i'll come back later i
got like 25 of them upstairs what do i
give a [__]
so i bit half and i threw it away when i
walked back do you know what that lady
said to me she didn't go back to your
room
you just threw it away now i'm not going
to let you in like what do you mean
they're gonna let me in my daughter
everybody was on the other side and i'm
you're not gonna let me [__] in i go
let me talk to your goddamn supervisor
here because something ain't right here
what do you care weed is legal in
california you know the deal i have
anxiety and i got to walk for [__] 18
hours i you know
so finally they all circle me the
supervisor comes over
we start talking the supervisor [__]
goes you know what
let them in the goddamn park
just let him in
what do you give a [__] and i looked and
i go you don't get paid enough
to give a [__] you know like what what's
wrong with you what do you give a [__]
if i take it's not like i'm taking a
[__] case of vodka in there giving
out the little [__] kids on ice
it's my own little personal edible well
i gotta tell you something i'm lucky and
we ate that half
because when we went on it's a small
world after all almost abandoned [__]
ship you understand me if i would have
had a [__] parachute i would have
jumped off that [__] ride i don't
know if you've been and it's a small
world after you you sit down and it
picks you up and you go through all
these [__] deserts they throw sand at
you and [__] you know all sudden you're
in an ocean you get hit with water
you're like what the [__] is going on
but it's tremendous i mean listen the
one thing about disney i like
is that it's clean
you could see that you listen i'm paying
you a buck 40
but this place is [__] clean now i
don't know there was a fist fight last
year
covered [__] it up who gives a [__] i
had a great time at hershey park
it was hotter than [__] this week i mean
it was hot jack
it was hot the day i was shooting
it was hot and i tell you i love to
shoot
you know every time i shoot a tv show
or a movie for one or two days it makes
me realize how much i miss that [__] i
don't want to do 10 weeks on a [__]
movie
i don't want to be on location for
[__] 13 weeks in the up upstate new
york at some [__] motel 6
because they want to be secluded you got
to drive an hour to the nearest [__]
hotel that's a four star i don't want to
deal with that i just want to zip into
the city
go to [__] wardrobe throw on my
little [__] fat man suit
go on the set do my [__] two or three
lines because i can't remember anything
more than that
like those big chunks of acting that
those days are done when i get the
audition i'm like i can't remember this
i got a teleprompter app on my [__]
computer and i have to use the
teleprompter app and sometimes you speed
it up it don't go fast enough sometimes
it goes fast enough
i try my best
i got a good meeting next week this week
this week coming up i got a great
meeting for a [__] movie they're
gonna zoom in
so i'm very excited about that what i
wanted to talk to you about on a
beautiful [__] monday first of all
the giant wants to congratulate michael
klein
he got engaged over the [__] weekend
you know uh
i'm very proud of him i take
it's just so weird how
you look at relationships and i can be
strictly honest with you guys
i was not ready for a relationship in my
20s
i was a [__] loser
i've been a [__] loser since i was 16
years old
for relationships i mean i started my
relationship world by getting left back
i fell in love with a girl that would
just give me [__] dry humps
how [__] am i and i got left to [__]
back you know and i'm proud enough to
talk about it today like i was ashamed
of it for [__] years i was ashamed of
it when it happens because i was a lot
smarter than that but to get [__]
left back
over no [__] is you got to be a [__]
idiot and that's what i did
so when i first started dating like
girls and stuff
i just kept running into problems i was
jealous i was [__] this
i was angry i was so every time i dated
a girl i had to pull back on something
that's the only good thing that when you
do something you learn you know what i'm
saying so yeah part of me wishes i never
dated in my 20s
but the other part of me
i'm glad i did because i learned a lot i
learned how to treat women i learned how
to act around women
but early on i was a [__] jerk off i
was a jerk off in relationships
until i was probably 32 or 33 and even
then i had [__] problems you know and
that's why
before i met terry i was like you know
what listen
nothing wrong with slinging dick
nothing wrong with eating somebody's
[__] on the road that you met you
know there's nothing wrong with that
it's natural procrastination is a part
of life god loves when you [__] he loves
it you know god loves it more kids
children of god all that [__]
god loves when you procreate
uh
i had nothing against that but i knew
that i was so much of a [__] loser
i didn't want to put a woman through
this again and the dog i put women
through dumb [__]
like i i just put i didn't give him a
heartache i didn't cheat on him nothing
like that i just didn't have no sense of
calling
coming at a certain time you know like
not coming sexually i mean like you know
coming home at a certain time i mean
i didn't have a mother figure you know
all through my life
that was like till i was 10 and then my
mother died when i was 16
but i didn't really have to answer
anybody is what i'm trying to say so it
was very tough for me as a as a man
it was very tough for me like when a
woman or anybody asked me what time are
you going to be home my blood pressure
goes up 180 over 100.
don't ask me what time i'm gonna be home
don't i don't [__] know
you know i like to tell you 11 but what
if i'm driving home
and there's a naked woman that just
escaped from a [__] cocksucker's
anonymous
uh rehab you know i'd love to tell you
what if i'm driving home and i got a
sudden urge to drive diarrhea and i got
to pull over to manalapan [__] diner
and [__] my ass off you know what i
don't know so don't ask i could try to
be home by a certain [__] time but
don't ask all those things bothered me
as a man
because i didn't have to deal with it
growing up you know it was all [__]
new to me you know
so when i left boulder like after my
divorce i didn't know how to handle a
[__] divorce
i didn't know how to handle a marriage
when i first got married
i couldn't handle [__]
do you understand me i couldn't handle
[__]
and i'm really [__] sorry about this
that that
i couldn't handle anything when i was
married i couldn't
i didn't know how to communicate i
didn't know how to
you know i still remember meeting my
ex-wife
like i was celibate for [__]
well it wasn't that i was celebrating i
couldn't get a piece because i wasn't
doing coke and my confidence was low
so i wouldn't talk to women you know i
knew how to talk to women when i got
coked up that's easier with three drinks
in you but once you're [__] sober you
don't know how to [__] talk to women
so i didn't [__] talk to women like
you know i didn't i didn't get laid from
[__]
84 like mid 84
to like june of 85. i was like on a
[__] 11 month
uh sabbatical from sex or
intimate [__] touching or nothing
you know and then i all of a sudden i
went on a [__] roll in 85 and i still
remember
dating my ex-wife and moving with her to
san francisco
and being alone with her in a hotel room
and thinking to myself wow
i'm living with a woman
like there's no
preparation there's no course you could
take
there's no not nothing i met her august
5th
and by august 20th we were living
together in a [__] hotel room
in san francisco and then by september
1st we were [__] living in a and a
full-time you know those hotels where
you have a room and the bathrooms in the
hallway and you share it with 20 [__]
people you got to walk there with your
robe on and with your [__] shaving
kit like a jerk off i didn't have a
[__] robe i'd have to walk in the
hallway with a towel on they'd tell me
to put his shirt on it was a [__]
nightmare but the point i'm trying to
make is that
i i didn't know what i was doing
i'm living with a [__] girl
this is great she's going to clean we're
going to have sex whenever i want
and i was like an animal like i would
come home every afternoon let's go let
me give you a stab and we'd watch
mission impossible at four o'clock and
after mission impossible i'd give her a
[__] stab and if i'm paying rent i
gotta get my [__] money's worth like
that's how you think when you're a
[__] kid
and you're a young man you don't [__]
know i wish i [__] knew
i had no idea
and i did the best i could you know i
treated like a friend i didn't [__]
know you want to smoke a joint you know
i would take her out to dinner i mean i
didn't [__] know
but then the evolution continues you
know and now you're you're a couple
and then we move back to [__] boulder
together and then we started hanging out
i got locked up you know it wasn't like
a traditional meet somebody in high
school
go to the prom with them
go to college you still date while
you're in college and then once you get
your degree and i get my degree we do it
the right way and we get a marriage i
didn't do none of that [__] that that
wasn't in my [__] path i was a
quickie type of dude i met you i either
like you or i don't like you you know
what i'm saying if i like you i'll call
again
if i don't like you i'm not going to
waste your [__] time i'm not in
business to [__] use people
so when i got married i got i didn't get
married for all the right [__]
reasons i got married because i knocked
somebody up
did i love it
who knows
you know we'll see later on you can
learn to love somebody that's what i
thought no you can't
either you love them or you don't
[__] love them yeah people grow on
you you know what i'm saying but you
have to have something there to sit
around that person every [__] day if
not you you want to stab yourself in the
eye every time they talk so i know i do
if i didn't like somebody i couldn't
have them around i'm not that
listen i learned the lessons lesson
early on when i was 16 don't use people
if you they're not you don't don't
well they got a fast boat you don't want
to be their friend
well they have good weed who gives a
[__] everybody's got good weed you can
buy good [__] weed you don't need to
[__] be somebody's friend
because they have [__] weed you know
but
when i got married i was totally
confused of what a marriage was it just
did not work for me guys
i mean a lot of you saw me last october
and november and december
i was [__] [__] i was burnt goods i
was burnt the [__] out
nothing
bothers me more than my time when i was
married from [__]
september of 89
to october 15 to 1991
we're coming on the anniversary now
[__] leaving
i was just not happy
i mean it was brutal for me i didn't
know what
you know and
looking back at it
it was a lot of things it was
me getting out of prison
and all of a sudden i get out of prison
and the next thing you know i'm getting
[__] married six months later and
i'm having a [__] kid
i was over [__] well
and something happened to me on the way
to the [__] prom
when i got married i got married on
saturday afternoon september 9th or i
know
who the [__] knows yeah 9 9 of 89
whatever the [__]
so it's september 9th of 89 check your
[__] calendar google that date there
was like two great college football
games that day like colorado was playing
nebraska
so i was pissed off already like i
didn't [__] know i never took that
into account that there was a great
college [__] football game on the day
i was gonna get [__] married you know
so
i didn't take none of that [__] until
time i didn't even think about it but
when when i got married man
the wedding was great you know the
reception was great
and then we had to get a ride to denver
stapleton airport that was the airport
then
we were headed to san francisco for a
honeymoon
and i remember we got on a plane it was
like a 9 40 flight get you to san
francisco like 11 o'clock
it was a 9 40 flight
i'll never forget getting on that plane
with a
you know like just coming back from a
wedding
you're high on the wedding my friends
were there mike ronnie was there one of
my best friends was my
my uh
best man you know
it couldn't have been any better you
know
i didn't do any coke until the end of
the wedding you know at the end because
i knew i didn't have to pee till
wednesday
so i didn't do any coke
till yeah i wasn't coming back to like
wednesday
so the p days for the halfway house uh
for the community corrections was monday
wednesday and friday so i knew i had a
green light i could get high because i
was going to come back wednesday but at
night time
and they weren't able to piss me on
thursday they were going to piss me on
friday so i already had it figured out
in my head
so towards the end like about 8 30 was
when i did a couple bumps just so nobody
would see me coked up just to you know
put a little [__]
gin in that indian
and i [__] went to the airport we got
on the plane when we get to the plane
there's maybe
i like to say 16 of us on the plane
and we're [__] spread out
and i'll never forget that my wife at
the time said to me i got a surprise for
you
and she she had a skirt on she split her
legs open and she had a garter belt
and i had sex with her right on the
plane like an animal that i was she was
like four months pregnant i didn't give
a [__]
i was coked up i had a couple whiskeys
in me a couple doers on the rocks i gave
her a stab and riding a [__] plane
and then
she sat by the window looking out the
window and i sat in the aisle seat
and i'll never [__] forget that i was
like
i think i made a mistake
when everything wore off the party wore
off
the sex wore off and i had a time to
think i'm like
i think i made a [__] mistake
this poor girl thinks that
her life is gonna be solved
and this poor girl has no idea that i
have no [__] idea
i'm a [__] idiot i don't know what's
going on here
she thinks like we're gonna [__] have
a house with a white picket fence
and life is gonna be great i can't cover
that spread
i'm a loser i can't do this [__]
and i remember like getting off that
plane with us going this is not gonna
[__] last i didn't say nothing to her
but i was
i was getting in the way of myself
looking back now i remember going to the
hotel going to hertz
renting a [__] nissan 240z
you know the [__] two the two-seater
in the front and you know there's no
reason to have a [__] back unless
you're a [__] with no legs you're not
gonna be able to sit back there it's
just somebody with no legs that can sit
back there there's no room if your seat
is all the way back
so i rented a 240 went back to the hotel
room as soon as we got back to the hotel
room she's like i'm tired sure she's
tired
she's four months [__] pregnant what
the [__] did i expect but joey diaz back
then couldn't comprehend that
like i'm like what do you mean you're
[__] tired who gives a [__] to be
pregnant let's keep this party alive
let's have some sex let's go get some
beers
she was like [__] i'm not going for
it so i was like i'm gonna go downstairs
and smoke some pot and maybe go for a
ride she's like fine i [__] ran over
to this bar
i was just taking i was just spitting in
the [__] wind but this is the luck i
had back then that's why i'm telling you
junkies have all the [__] luck
i just took a fight i lived in san
francisco in 85.
it was now 89
and i had a friend a cuban friend called
bamboozy tough [__] me and him
used to sling drugs and travelers checks
and [__] play dice
on the in the tenderloin we ran a
[__] game he was tremendous me and
him used to [__] cash travelers
checks you stolen credit cards
him and i were like a [__] team him
and i and this guy named lazaro
lazaro was a [__] trip to his little
olderness if we were in our 20s me and
bamboo see lazaro was like 45 but he was
a [__] trip
so
i just took a chance i remember the bar
with bamboozy
hung out at
and i [__] had to find my way around
san francisco i didn't know any street
names mason you know all this [__]
and i remember going to that bar going
inside
and there's [__] bamboo
it's got to be midnight and i haven't
seen him in four years i gave him a big
[__] hug he was happy to see me we
had a drink and ryan go who's got an
eight ball
and he goes i got one let's go give it
to me i sat with him till closing time
whatever that [__] was he had some
girl he was leaving with i had nobody i
basically went in my 240zx i went to the
hotel parking lot and i just sat there
all night snorting the coke figuring how
am i gonna get out of this [__]
marriage
this is [__] i can't be [__]
married
i did the whole [__] eight ball by
myself i drank like
a bottle of wine there was some [__]
individual beers
a few wine coolers about seven o'clock
i [__] finished drinking i must have
jerked off in the car in a bag or
whatever when you're [__] coked up
and you're a junkie you do the most
disgusting [__] things
i must have jerked off in my hand like
cappuccino style you come right in the
palm and then you [__] wipe it on the
front on the
furniture i must have done one of those
i'm not lying to you guys i actually
jerked off in the car that's when you do
when you do coke by yourself
and i went upstairs and i'll never
forget that i [__] went upstairs
tippy-toed in
picked up the sheet got in the bed
put the sheet on
and within eight minutes
she turned around looked at me she goes
good morning
and i'm like good morning to you and i'm
like trying to like hide my face because
i'm [__] blasted and i reek of
alcohol she's like how was your night i
go good i went out i had a few drinks
and i just got home i just got a nap for
an hour and i'll be ready for you she's
like that's fine i wanted to take a walk
around san francisco anyway i'm like i
had knocked yourself out and i [__]
went to sleep and i felt no remorse
i didn't feel bad i was like this is not
gonna [__] work
but
you know eventually i'll fall in love
with i didn't know i was
i mean i cared for i don't want you
people to think i'm a [__] savage
with a bone in my nose i cared for her
i loved her in a way but
marriage
i wasn't [__] ready to be married to
anybody
i played the game
we went to the [__] giant game
we did this we went to [__]
fisherman's wharf we went to guadalajara
square and got some chocolate you know
the [__] deal
but when we got back to boulder it was
like
this is not gonna [__] work
she was more of a roommate
than a [__] wife i felt you know a
lot of ways
so i played the [__] game you know we
uh
i think right after i got [__]
married
i went into such a [__] funk
that i started snorting with three hands
again and by october i gave him a hot
at the [__] uh
at the halfway at the community
corrections
and they actually threw me in the
halfway house for a 90-day violation
so here's my wife [__] seven months
pregnant
and i'm in a [__] halfway house this
was a formula
for failure i mean we already were
[__] failing you know
it was rough it was a rough three months
i had to apologize to a family but this
marriage was just
it was just sad and then
i was thinking oh well maybe i'll have
the kid and that'll change me once i see
the kid physically
i'll stop snorting coke
and i'll get my life together well let
me tell you how [__] much that helped
she had the baby i got out of the
halfway house february 2nd
she had the baby february 3rd
at like 10 in the morning
and i was doing cocaine at 7 o'clock
february third at my house
with my brother-in-law her brother so
and then i snorted sunday and you know
that genuine cocaine talk
this is the last line i'll do fatherhood
is gonna change me
you know god put a kid in my life so i
could stop snorting coke and be a better
person
you know how much that worked nothing
seeing that kid did nothing to me seeing
that kid just put more pressure on me
made me more [__] scared than what i
was
and i [__] went overboard but i
once i was back in the halfway house i
had to prove to everybody and i made it
all the way to level four
they had me driving i was like an
example
[__] uh inmate invict
and
i [__] got it but here's how [__]
weird life is
so i get out on friday
february 2nd we went to lucille's in
boulder i got the [__] bayonets
i got the red snapper with three [__]
sunny side up eggs
and it was a beautiful day it was like
cloudy out the sun was trying to push
through
i remember i went back to our apartment
we lived behind uh abo's pizza and
ledizio on 30th street
i had been living in such a stressful
situation
i didn't know you never [__] know
that you get out of a stressful
situation
that i was in a stressful situation so
when i got to the house that day we got
home about two maybe three o'clock
we laid down i [__] passed that
i mean i passed out
all the way to saturday morning at like
six a.m
when she woke me up to tell me her water
[__] broke
she's like my water broke i'm like what
the [__] are you talking about
i knew nothing about waters
i knew nothing about bags i knew nothing
about babies i knew nothing about
nothing
she's like my [__] water broke i'm
like what do you want me to do i'm not a
doctor she's like we got to get to the
[__] hospital i'm like hospital are
you [__] crazy
so i'll never forget i go outside to the
[__] get the car
i [__] look out the window
and this could only happen in colorado
there's a foot and a half of snow out
from [__] it partially sunny was
coming out on [__] uh
friday
till there's a [__] foot and a half
of snow on the goddamn floor
i'm like what the [__] is this
so now i gotta go out there she's
yelling she's like oh
oh
and i'm like what the [__] is this
and i go outside i [__] shovel i
gotta pull the car out i gotta shovel
under the [__] car i gotta shovel the
cars on the whole time i got the heat i
got the [__]
sun the blink is going i pull the
[__] car out i shovel the [__]
spot you know i leave a little trail
there i pull the car out a little bit
more i [__]
shovel out the [__] spot and you're
not gonna believe what happens
while i'm getting back in my car i see a
guy
turn onto the block and he's coming
towards me
now i knew the guy he lived not on top
of me i didn't talk to him we didn't
drink we didn't hang out together he
wasn't my friend i just knew he lived
upstairs
i see him coming towards me i go that's
interesting
all sudden there were you know you had
cones in front of your house you [__]
you cleaned out the driveway now it's
your parking spot you put the two cones
there
so i was gonna get in the car to
straighten out the car and then put the
two cones there open the door tell my
wife the car was ready i put a little
pat in the snow so she could walk it was
all planned out you know me i don't [__]
around what do you think scumbag does
coming at me he comes at me
and he turns into my parking spot
and just pulls in
i'm like what the [__] just happened
i get out of the car
i knock on his car he gets out of the
car go ahead dog i don't mean to be a
[__] painty ass or rude but i was
just out here 30 minutes shoveling when
my wife is inside yelling you could hear
a [__] yelling her water broke i have
to take it to the [__] hospital
and i just [__] cleaned this spot out
and you're just gonna
[__] stroll in here and park in the
thing
i swear to god guys i just got out of
the halfway house
i'm trying to get my life together
this [__] looks me straight in
the face
turns around looks at my car and spits
at my [__] car and he goes too bad
i'm like this
did not just [__] happen
my life is a [__] game show
this did not just [__] happen that
this guy spit in my [__] car
i just got out of the halfway house
my wife is pregnant she's inside [__]
yelling you're not gonna believe this
[__] story i'm like are you [__]
serious he's like it's too [__] bad
i'm taking the spot shovel another one
you're not gonna need it anyway you're
gonna be in the hospital you know what
that's true
that that's one frame of thought
but he didn't say it that way he came
out of the car like a [__] jerk off
and i wasn't taking it so i [__]
choked them we started swinging each
other right there bop bop we started
[__] swinging at each other he hit me
with two or three good [__] shots to
the head i was reaching for [__] air
and next thing you know this
[__] went to grab me he slipped
in the snow sorry charlie i got right on
top of him and i started banging his
[__] head off the [__] snow right
i'm banging his head off the [__]
snow i'm punching him i'm trying to bite
him in the [__] hand cause he's
trying to [__] i'm trying to nibble
on his [__] glove and [__]
and the next thing you know he's pushing
my face i'm punching him
and you're not gonna believe this
two cop cars
with their [__] lights on
are coming at me
and i'm like this ain't [__]
happening
this is not [__] happening i'm going
to go right back to [__] jail
i'm on top of the guy i'm [__]
pounding him he's he's pushing me
here's what gets better the cops run out
of the car and i see it's one of the
cops i know
i'm like oh thank god maybe he'll cut me
a break i'm like what's going on man i'm
sorry this [__] guy
they go no we're not here for a fight
we're here for a complaint of domestic
violence i go domestic violence
who's domestic violence saying anybody
it's my [__] neighbor he goes we're
not even here for that
some somebody complained that they heard
a woman yelling like that's my wife
she's about to have a kid the water just
broke and i'm trying to explain the
story to them and they're like all right
all right well we got to take care of
this what happened here and i'm like
this [__] i just shoveled and
this [__] pulls into my spot and
the cops like well listen there's no law
i'm like it's not that the way the
[__] came out of the car he came
out with a bad attitude it's not what
you're saying it's how you say it [__]
him we're going back and forth the cops
like enough already enough he goes
listen get your wife in the car
we're gonna [__] one car's gonna get
behind you one car is gonna get in front
of you and we're gonna [__] escort
you to the hospital
you two [__] idiots
shake i i thought they went into a
circle like a powwow i thought they were
gonna throw me under the jail i just
been out [__] 12 hours i'm about 12
[__] hours and i'm going back to
[__] jail this ain't happening this
is not [__] happening
the next thing you know
they come out of the huddle and they're
like listen
we're just going to write this off as a
bad day
all right i'm like thank god
they're like shake hands i'm like listen
at this point i'll do anything
just to get her to the hospital she's in
the [__] doorway
so i'm like [__] this [__] i go to put
my hand down and this [__] goes
i ain't shaking his hand
the office of my friend walks up to me
goes listen
we could just get in the car and leave
you weren't doing too good when we got
here this gorilla was about to [__]
level you
so what do you want to do the guy shook
my hand [__] reluctantly
i grabbed my wife and the [__] cops
escorted us to the [__] airport like
not the airport the hospital like
nothing [__] happened that that that
that's the pre that's [__] six months
of our married life
i just broke down to you the first six
months were [__] horrible then the
kid came along
i loved that child with all my heart
but listen man
a kid wasn't going to change the animal
i was the time that just wasn't going to
happen
and i'll tell you i had a little bit of
[__] depression
you couldn't tell like i know looking
back now
that i had a little bit of depression at
that time just a little tad you know
but at the same [__] time when i had
the baby
as sad as this is gonna sound my
daughter jacqueline
that even put me farther out there
that made me feel even worse than what i
did my self-esteem was low
i had a hard time being a man i wasn't
gonna be a [__] father
how was i even gonna be a [__] father
you know and i
pushed through it i pushed through it
and i had another struggle going on
i was being a [__]
i should have been on stage the day
after i got off [__] out of prison
in february of 89 i should have [__]
been on stage the next night
it was [__] february of 90
and i still wasn't on [__] stage
who's the biggest [__] you know uncle
joey procrastinator uncle [__] joey i
still wouldn't go on [__] stage
so i i was an unhappy marriage
i was not a good [__] father even
though i was a good father i don't want
you guys to get me wrong i was in i was
changing diapers i just felt
not up the paw
like i saw what other dads looked like
and i saw how they were acting
and i just failed i was just a failure
at it
you know and to top it off
i wasn't living the life i wanted to
which is heavy
heavy i even i you know
one of the reasons mike is here was his
[__] hatred
for his office shot he did not like it
he did not like it when you're a
musician and you're a free spirit a day
job is like a [__] suicide sentence
and i know i know how because i [__]
been there i did 30 jobs i didn't want
to do i did them to pay the [__] rent
or to snort coke or whatever [__]
excuse i have
but i did all those [__] uh
jobs just to get by they weren't because
i was in love with something
you don't know what life is to you love
your [__] child
when you love your job and you're
supposed to be there at eight and you're
getting there at 7 15
that's love when you don't love your job
it's a death sentence and you're not
living the life you lit and even if you
go you know what i'm no [__] jimmy
page
i'm never gonna be in led zeppelin you
know what that's okay
that's okay
there's a restaurant
that loves when you come down with an
acoustic guitar
and you do a couple beatles songs
from eight to nine whatever i don't
help i need somebody help not just
anybody help you know what i'm saying
one thing that i realized as a comic was
that
you didn't really have to go to la i
don't ever want you to feel like you had
to go to l.a
you could be a comic a musician an
artist
right in your little [__] pocket of
the world
i could have stayed in denver and been
just as happy
as i would have gone to l.a or seattle
or whatever i wouldn't have been the
same comic i probably wouldn't have had
the same opportunities
but that would have still made me a
comic
so
when i was
i was just on the [__] happy
i just was not there as a as a married
guy
it just didn't work out for me finally
in july
she did me the biggest favor of my life
she overheard me on the phone she knew i
was having a tough time at the time i
had two [__] jobs
i was a roofing estimator i basically
went home washed my [__] and [__]
went to the comedy club the witch hunt
to be a [__] doorman and then i got
promoted to a sound guy then i was a bar
back then i was doing all three jobs by
myself
and then i finally had the balls to get
on stage and then
you know i mean
september of 91.
i was so [__] unhappy
my ex-wife came to me
and she was like listen you got on stage
because now i was even unhappier
i should have been [__] ecstatic that
i got on stage but there was a problem i
still had a [__] day job
and i tell you what that was not a day
job i hated i never hated roofing
estimating it was easy i enjoyed it but
it wasn't what i wanted to do till i was
65 and get a gold watch
that's not what i wanted to do
that was no he was a great roofer yeah
here's a gold watch thank you for your
38 years of service you [__] luke
thank you for making us eight million
dollars with your knowledge you [__]
maluk
you know so i was like that's not what i
want to do
i want to [__] do stand-up [__]
comedy
and man i look at my marriage now the
first time it just wasn't it was just
like pink floyd says in dogs
we were just roommates
you know i loved stand up so [__]
much at that time
that i was really [__] upset i loved
my daughter
i loved stand up i did not like being
married
i did not like answering to somebody
i just did not like my [__] life
but i also knew
that my life wasn't miraculously gonna
change it just doesn't miraculously
change
it's like my life now this past year
i've had to put in [__] work and
journaling and writing and the therapist
i've had to put in [__] work at that
time i didn't really [__] know what i
was doing
i just knew i was not [__] happy
she even came to me one day like in
september she's like listen
i think you should take a [__] trip
i think
you need something in that short period
of time i started stand up
i signed up at naropa institute i was
treading on the idea of becoming a
buddhist
you know i mean i was [__] up guys
[__] up over this marriage it was not
[__] happiness for me
but i did not know how to get out of
this her parents were really good to me
her family was my family
and i was stuck
i was stuck and didn't even know it
i was like those people on the island
naked and afraid
you will see those people [__] it's
bad enough being afraid now you're naked
that's a real [__] bond burner now
people got to see my [__] covertoe i
don't need that aggravation in my life
so when i walked in that [__] october
15th
and she came to me and she's like hey
i'm not happy this is not working
i had a a euphoric [__] surge go
through my body i was like oh
really
you cut me out of this prison sentence
because it was a [__] prison sentence
as far as i'm concerned
and i'll tell you what when she packed
up her [__] bags
and walked out of that door
i gotta be honest with you guys
i was the happiest [__] man
to walk their [__] earth
i loved her to a degree
and i cared for her i wasn't crazy about
it i could live with that
i didn't like
being with somebody that i wasn't
totally heads over heels over
i didn't feel
adequate as a father even though i stuck
it out with her
for four years six seven eight years
after that trying to be a father
i just knew one thing when that marriage
ended that i was not doing this again
i was not doing this to myself i was not
going to do this to another woman
this was never happening again you want
to [__] you want to start some coke you
want me to eat your [__]
i'm in
but i'm not
getting in no monogamous
situations or anything
that was
how i felt in 1990 [__] five
that was exactly how i felt when i some
summarized my marriage and what had
happened
since 1985
when i met
my ex-wife i had summarized all that and
i came to the conclusion that
i'm not good for anybody
i'm a [__] loser
um i'm happy i have comedy i don't have
to [__] worry about insurance or
phone bills or mortgage i'm gonna get in
this car i'm gonna [__] go on the
road and that's what i'm gonna [__]
do
never again
will i weigh down a woman with my
[__] my uh
you know stupidity i'm not gonna do this
and it's [__] up when you think that
way because when you're not looking for
somebody
is when you find somebody it's like when
vito left the sopranos and he [__]
went up to maine and he found that
[__] half a [__] the cook who
committed suicide rest in peace remember
they got into an argument and he says to
him i wasn't even looking for you you
know
it's the same thing when you're not when
you're not looking for somebody
that's when you find somebody you know
when i met my [__] wife
sorry about that i i was just thinking
about it i have to [__] paint the
picture for you [__] you know
what i'm saying
so
yeah yeah i'm like bob ross before the
operation
uh so
when i met terry
terry had everything i loved in a woman
not to mention she was from the south i
i loved that i heard all these things
about southern women
and i still remember being with her the
first 90 days
and like one day i got to a house i was
broke and she made me a [__] great
lunch
of [__] cuban beans she [__] did
it up red beans i was so [__] excited
but there was still that doubt i had i
had a doubt that
i'm not gonna make her happy i'm gonna
let her down
you know in every perspective you know
emotionally
sexually
i'm [__] fire i'm a dud you know i
know this going in that i'm a [__]
dud
how am i gonna
[__]
for the first six months i dated terry i
did like her
i did have feelings for her i was
starting to love her and i didn't want
to
i was like i'm not gonna hurt this girl
i'm gonna stick around here for a couple
weeks
until she tells me i'm a bum like
everybody else
and then
you know i'll move on i'll find the new
girl
when i look at terry this week when we
went to hershey and we were walking in
the park
and there was one point like me and her
connected like synchronized in a way
because she was going for a walk and i
had a phone call to make
and i'm sitting there making this call
and i look up in this [__] nathan's
hot dogs right
and i go holy [__] maybe they got
lemonade so i saw these people walking
around with a lemonade
and i go i woke up and there's no
[__] lemonade but i saw chili dogs
i'm like [__] i go for a chili dog but i
gotta watch my weight watcher points
those chili dogs are a [__]
so i go awesome my wife texts me she
goes we're under the umbrella because it
was really hot there was a big umbrella
where you could sit there and drink
something so i walk over and i go we
gotta get lemonade my wife goes [__]
that i'm [__] starving i go holy [__]
i bought a chili dog from nathan's and
on the walk over
i was like holy [__] me and my wife
are synchronized
like we ate breakfast together you know
she had like a snack she's on noon
whatever that diet
she's lost like eight pounds she loves
it and uh
we were both [__] hungry and we both
like [__] looked at each other at the
same time and after we had that chili
dog
we were walking in the park and i'm like
i can't believe
i've been with this woman for 21 [__]
years
there was a time when i couldn't be with
a woman for 21 minutes
like nobody wanted to be next to me i i
have worked it out with that and i
and i still remember being with her
at the three-year mark
and her asking me
what are we doing
and me going i don't know
and i'm going like you got to make a
move pretty soon
and
it was like me telling my mother i got
live back
i didn't want to tell terry i didn't
want to get married because i knew
she would tell me then you got to go
i put that [__] marriage off
for nine years
nine years i want to be absolutely
positively
sure that i wasn't going to waste her
time
i wasn't going to waste her life
and i could be a good husband
i was at the [__]
crossroads
before i quit drugs with her because i
thought i would never get off drugs
and i didn't want to put that on her and
then finally i looked at her one day and
i go you know what
i got to take a higher [__] road i
got to stop doing drugs because i don't
want her to [__] find me
and when i did that
that's when i knew
she was the woman for me after i stopped
the drugs
i go you know what at the year mark
i'll ask her to propose
she didn't say nothing so i'm like i'm
the other [__] proposed [__] that
i could do this for as long as we could
do this i could do this well let me tell
you something
she went to tennessee
and when she came back after like four
days she went to visit her parents and
she went to see her
child her brother had a child and when
my wife came back she wasn't the same
person
she just wasn't the same person
and i remember i [__]
beat around the bush for about three or
four months
and i was like what am i gonna do
she's not gonna [__] stop you know
she wasn't even
she wasn't even forcing me or nothing i
could just tell that she wasn't happy
she was uh a 30-something year old woman
she was single
she wasn't married she didn't have a
child we were living in a [__] studio
apartment we had no money we had a
shitty [__] car
i mean our prospects were [__]
horrible what was i gonna [__] do
and i'll never forget one day i went to
a santeria [__] read with my karate
teacher we were talking
and he's like there's a woman in your
life that isn't really happy
and i i knew exactly what he was talking
about
when i got in the car i did not hesitate
i called her father
i asked her for a hand in marriage
and then i called terry and i go listen
we're getting married
[__] in two months
i talked to your dad we're gonna order a
ring tonight i i want you to say yes
and i knew you know that i was going out
on the limb
but i knew i do i work a lot better when
i got a gun to my head
some instances you know i'm saying in
some instances i work a lot better with
a gun to my head sometimes i don't need
a gun to my head
but uh
i married him
i married her and i had no [__]
regrets
and now we've been married
for 12 years we've been together for 21.
and
i grew into the man i wanted to become
man it's uh
it's a weird thing
i just wanted mike to know that i had
his back i know a lot of you guys out
there
are thinking about getting engaged or
whatever just be prepared
just know that this is what you want to
do
listen man being a husband is not
[__]
it's the hardest thing i've done because
i'm a [__] idiot but you guys are
educated you came from well homes you
came from good homes you have families
you had a little basic education on
communicating with people and whatever
it's a great thing being married i know
for some people it doesn't work
some people just get turned off by it i
was being
a [__] jerk off
by saying i'm never going to be [__]
married again because i knew it was
[__]
i knew eventually i would find the right
person i didn't know who wanted to be
with my [__] fat ass but i also knew
that i had a lot to offer
so
when i put the [__] ring on a finger
i knew i had a [__] change
to be the best man i could be from a to
[__] z
and at the age of 58 i'm happy to say
i'm here i'm i'm [__] this this is
the best joey diaz you'll ever see right
now
and i'm looking forward to the next 10
years of her
12 years i'm having a great time
i'm having a great time and
it's it it's there's a big difference
between being a bad husband and a good
husband it's just a little bit of work
that's just a little bit of work
doing things that you're not told to do
you know my my wife never has to tell me
to do something i take pride in her not
having to go joey take the garbage out
joey can you go grocery shopping joey
can you watch mercy you know i already
[__] have my day planned out in my
head i know what i could do with my
daughter and i try to be the best i can
and it's the thing i take most pride in
yeah i did comedy for 30 years that's
great i also was with a woman for 21
years
and that's also great that takes a lot
of [__]
sacrifice commitment
and love you know so
i don't know if you get married i don't
know if you're thinking about getting
married
but if you're thinking about getting
married think about it's not going to
end in divorce
that you're going to be the best man
that you could be
divorce is for [__] punks trust me i
got divorced and it happens
listen you got to kiss a [__] [__]
you got to kiss a couple bumpies before
you get that queen you know what i'm
saying nobody meets the first person at
the the first time and if you do
good luck to you and i'm happy for you
but you're gonna have to kiss a couple
morons a couple people have bad breath
some chick has sperm breath you deal
with it
and uh you move on but you're gonna find
the person for you but when you find
that person
give it a hundred percent like i said
it's
it's this much difference my fingers
are a quarter of an inch apart right now
for you people that are listening not
watching
it's a quarter of an inch to be a great
husband
or to be a shitty husband that's it
it's that simple it's it's and it's
and when you're [__] doing great at
it you feel great about yourself i feel
great about myself
for years i was [__] depressed that i
failed at marriage it is the basic the
most basic thing that we have in our
lives think about it it's a relationship
hello goodbye i love you i'll stop here
you sacrifice you get you know and i
failed at it dramatically and i was
[__] ashamed i didn't tell nobody i
just my excuse was i'll never get
married again well
no
you get married again and you be the
best
[__] man that you could be
that's monday's joint with uncle joey
it's the 30th the [__] in august
i enjoyed myself today i love these
little monday ear beatings as you could
tell i'm folding back into the old joey
diaz little by little room wasn't built
in a day but i'm feeling great about it
i'm still doing my better help
and i'm still doing my journaling i'm
still lifting my weights
and it's [__] september [__]
so we're 30 days away
31 days away from the many saints of
newark we got a lot of surprises for you
this month we got some great guests for
you this month so sit tight the joint is
here to blow you the [__] away
laughing gas is back in stock
[__]
so they just got a big shipment on
friday i heard it's [__] better than
the original shipment hopefully my buddy
goes out to la next week and picks me up
a couple packages and we'll be back in
[__] black you understand me
but until wednesday i love you
[__] i want to congratulate
michael klein again on getting engaged
and i want to thank you guys for all the
support
for the [__] great messages for
that thing that rogan put up with uh
judy canciotti and me taking my dick out
behind the curtain
you guys [__] hit me up a thousand
times thank you you know i love making
you laugh
and that's it [__] i love you
have a great [__] monday
that's it it's the end of the week at
the end of the month the rent is due on
wednesday and we'll be back on
[__] wednesday i love your
[__] with all my heart and now
for a word
for my [__] sponsor jack
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank you for listening to the
podcast today
i hope that it helps you out with your
marriage or any commitments that you're
doing
and i want to thank you for always
having my back i want to congratulate
mike again and like i said in the
beginning laughing gas is back in stock
at the ice cream parlor in studio city
after this shipment we're gonna start
sending some off
to other stores i will keep you guys
posted we will write them down on
laughing gas at instagram at laughing
gas on instagram
but before i go
from the heart of new jersey deep in
[__] jersey the joint is brought to
you by draftkings
the nfl is back and you're getting paid
like a [__] doctor draftking
sportsbook is the official sports
betting partner of the nfl giving all
new players a hell of an offer
for the first week just bet one dollar
on any game
and cash 200
in free bets no matter what you heard it
right free [__] money at draftkings
we're giving all new players
200 bucks and a free bets when you place
one dollar bet on any week one game week
first week at nfl
is the [__] 12th i think that's the
first one if i'm correct
so you got two weeks to get your party
started get your picks in order study
your teams
see what the draft picks are and get
everything together they also have
baseball they also have a casino that is
[__] world-class to none from
blackjack to poker to roulette head to
draftkings sportsbook app now to check
out all their great promotions and daily
odd boosts plus make every game
a [__] same game parlay that's what
i'm talking about
download the draftking sports book app
today
use promo code joey to receive 200 and
free bets when you place a dollar bet on
any week one game that's promo code joey
to get your 200
and free bets instantly for a limited
time only at draftkings sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
nfl and the ufc you got to be 21 year
old or older new jersey indiana and
pennsylvania only new customers only
this deal is only for good new customers
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details i'm gonna tell
you what they did though
they're gonna they sent me an email the
other day if i deposited money
as an old player they were gonna take
care of me with some credits
they gave me minimum credits but they
took care of me with a bunch of opt-in
deals
like the yankee game last night they
gave me a free bonus on that like an
extra
op on yards listen draftkings is the way
to go plus they have live betting i
would not bust your balls it's fun it's
easy it's reliable and safe
draftkings.com
sportsbook download it today if you got
a gambling problem call 1-800 gambler if
you're in indiana call 1 809 with it but
if we're ready to rock the [__] house
download the draftking sportsbook app
today and win some do-ray me
the joint is also brought to you by
blue chew joey what's blue chew
listen you're getting older
you have a little ed you have problems
blue chew will take care of it blue chew
is an online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis at a fraction of the cost
you could take it any time day or night
the process is simple sign up at
bluechew.com and talk to one of the
licensed medical providers
once you're approved you rescue you
receive the prescription within days the
best part of it it's all online nobody
knows nothing no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations no
standing online at the pharmacy no the
whole thing it ships right to your door
in a discreet package not even your
mailman knows listen
you want to tear that [__] monkey up
right you want to make a good impression
blue chew tablets are for you they're
made in the usa and they're prepped and
shipped directly it's way cheaper than
any pharmacy
go to bluechew.com for a little extra
confidence next time you give her or him
a stabbing and they got a special deal
for you try blue chew free what are you
talking about joey free for free with
promo code joey just pay five hours for
shipping that's bluechew.com promo code
joey to receive your first month free
and as always i want to thank bluechu
for sponsoring the podcast i want to
thank bluechu
and i want to thank draftkings
the number one sports betting site in
the [__] world
for sponsoring the show today and i want
you guys to take advantage of blue chew
so you could sling dick with three hands
you could throw your dick over your
shoulders like doc
and draftkings so you can make some
[__] money whether it's
baseball
nba which is coming october 19th but the
thing the situation at hand is the nfl
in college football
place a one dollar bet and win 203
credits i think they give you 100 for
college football so you might as well go
with the nfl i love you guys with all my
heart
draftkings bluetooth.com
both of them code joey i'll see you
[__] wednesday tip top
[__] magoo
love you [__]
you